dude like there's this rapper named
Viper I don't think I never heard of it
there's it's like probably like this 47
year old rapper forty some forty
something at one point he had in his bio
the first trillionaire rap
[Music]
Viper where does he live my homie Dean
shouts out the D and he showed me this
dude the first trillionaire rapper album
who is that group I don't even want to
think I don't want to even try to go
down this rabbit hole right now let's do
it
we're ready here I can't even think of
the name of them they're like they're
like they're not this there I want to
say they do a lot of shows with the
suicide boys
they're called it's like it's like three
dudes and they go on stage and they
scream and they make weird sounds the
lead dudes they're like this big afro
he's like he's like [ __ ] belches into
the microphone and screams what the [ __ ]
is that band called duh it's the
something the that's narrowing at Google
though maybe we'll find bands that start
with yeah that's what I didn't want to
bring this up to never find it and work
through it and they play with suicide
boys mm-hmm yeah shouts out suicide boys
I've seen them hell yeah I've seen them
perform for the first time last last
August me and Pablo was out in LA he was
out there for like a week and on the PR
that we was working with they also do
work for suicide boys mm-hmm so it was
like yeah like we can get you in a
suicide boy so if you want because
they're here for the weekend and
actually there was performing at the
same venue twice so that was that one
they performed
Friday night and Saturday night the same
venue just because the first night they
[ __ ] sold out home say they ran the
same [ __ ] show back the next day so I
was like oh [ __ ] oh yeah I'm down
because like um I'd already knew screams
screaming Ruby yeah and they are they
dad hit me up a few months ago you know
I'm saying so I was like oh okay well be
able to meet them you know this show was
nuts bro like so we're like on the
balcony looking down at the show and
when they like any time they said open
up the pit there wasn't just one mosh
pit it was literally like seven eight
different circles Wow within one big one
there's because there's one just huge
one and then there's other like multiple
pits like spread your ass anything like
that
I've seen stuff like that yeah it's
amazing to see you said it's hypnotizing
yeah cuz we're at the top balcony just
looking at everything like yo that's
what our yeah in LA we're at The Wiltern
yeah what venue was there like I think
of an LA has a double story like that
the will turn never seen nothing like
that no as big as who ran into Kenny
beets there for the first time shouts
out Kenny be okay oh [ __ ] what was that
was like a nightmare
yeah it doesn't like a nightmare yo damn
yo so like even getting into that show
was like so stressful because like when
we went there Pablo had brung his camera
and he attacks me he was like yo is it
cool if I bring my camera and I was like
yeah yeah so we [ __ ] get there and we
talked to the people at a we'll call
we're like yeah like we're on the list
whatever and they're like okay you're on
the list but you can't bring the camera
we just stuck with this camera
now we got a way for the people at our
PR to get there and they had to talk to
a bunch of people and it was it was a
lot for a camera but I get it
yeah that's [ __ ] cuz we did get in
there for free and we got the best seats
in now any film that and you film it
right took pictures how often you guys
shoot videos um pretty often even if we
for like how many songs that you do do
you - make a video for yeah yeah like in
a lot of [ __ ] that there's a lot of
videos that aren't a ball that like have
never been released so in a lot of
videos that are unfinished so there's a
lot of concepts that we start working on
probably don't finish you know I'm
saying
yeah and a lot of [ __ ] that like that we
did a couple years ago and we look back
on now and we're just like oh well
really want to drop that feel different
about yeah we'll just let it you know
event yeah yeah was at the pub sub I
mean all that you're not a real
Floridian unless you've been drunk as
hell in public were you wait wait wait
were you grazing grazing is when you get
[ __ ] up in Publix when you first you
got to crack a 4-pack of some sort of
beer and then you go up and down the
aisles while you're shopping you eat the
food and then you just leave the car and
then you just 4-pack in the pool you're
drinking a four pack you keep that right
in the front of the cart drink your beer
and then you go up and down the aisles
and while you're getting shopping you
just eat food right shopping and then
you leave you just leave everything you
don't pay for anything no I was already
[ __ ] up before I got this was this was
set in stone and like was correct I
think we went back there twice just to
reshoot
yeah cuz I usually come down on you when
you try to film in there yeah it was
funny as I had so I got this little bill
dog and like chant I got a name tag for
the little bill dog yeah my little bill
is officially a Publix employee I don't
even go I don't even think I got the
name tag what is it show me the pub/sub
well goddamn we just did two hours big
baby scumbag yeah we just went through
it that was about two hours exactly I
think now I got one last question what
is it actually like touring for you cuz
I have my tour experience and I just
want to know what like your tour
experience is like because I'm like
coming at it from like I bought a van
off a Craigslist and then we would play
shows and usually sleep wherever we play
like on the floor or in somebody's
kitchen or in a basement with no air
conditioning all our money was spent on
just like drugs and cheap beer and so I
want to know like what the experience is
as a DIY hip-hop artist oh it's pretty
chill man like okay like for me me
personally it's like I don't smoke but
all of my homies smoke like well Pablo
doesn't smoke you like occasion that
will at the at the time of
yeah not at the time that we was on tour
Paulo wasn't smoking so it was two
people that didn't smoke on the bus
everybody else [ __ ] had a bus
yeah we had like a like a van like a
[ __ ] Sprinter Mercedes Sprinter at
that time a rockstar a mercedes sprinter
yeah it was a Ford DJ right so this
might have been right after a show bro I
don't know why I chuck was even driving
so our DJ was driving right we get to
Seattle and we're at our Airbnb our DJ
is backing up and he [ __ ] yeah not
there's a backup camera on okay there's
there's clearly a backup that must have
been a sprinter he wasn't using it [ __ ]
nah brah he's busted one in the windows
so there's two back there's two back
windows for your haters there's a window
in the window for the other door and he
buses one of the [ __ ] windows in the
back dude like I remember the the van
being with a broken window for laughs
the whole tour cuz yeah it was a trash
bag on it Giada was like the third or
fourth stop bro that was like a twenty
city tour we yo we had a [ __ ] trash
bag [ __ ] tape and like all you were
here when we was on the highway
yo but not toy toy it was cool man like
really like that was my first my Toba
Oliver Francis 2018 that was my first
like nationwide tour because I'd always
been on I'd always been on toys like
throughout Florida like three four or
five dates at a time but nothing like 20
city tour yes we hang out three
international dates so for me it was
just like I rolled with the punches man
like I didn't care about [ __ ] yeah cuz
really it wasn't even it wasn't that bad
it was some days that we did sleep in
the van but it was just like that whole
experience for me it was just like
whatever do like yeah I'm saying like
cuz you're not just going through it
alone man like a lot of the homies that
were on the bus experience the
experience in the same [ __ ] so you know
I'm saying not only that but it was like
we were all just excited to have the
opportunity to be on tour like you're
there I'm saying like we're here like
you know it's something that you've
thought about for so long as it guys
want to go on tour it what is that like
what is that like and then you're there
yeah and you're just you're living in it
yeah man like shaking hands and [ __ ]
with like all your fans and just just
interact in his life like every show
like I would look into the crowd and it
would be that one moment like time would
just like freeze and in my head I would
be like yo like I would be performing
going along with the words and [ __ ] but
my head was like yo like what the [ __ ]
is going alright I'm O what I'm rapping
like I'm doing all it is you gotta
remind yourself sometimes yeah just like
stop thinking about it it's a lot of
it'll a lot of [ __ ] happy like it'll be
a lot of [ __ ] and like it'll like snap
in my head like you know I can't think
of none that it's hot off the top of my
head
yeah do like being on tour was great
experience
[Laughter]